[Music]
[Music]
welcome to tactics time today we're
gonna learn about double attack and
without wasting any time let's get an
example up on the board nothing to solve
here just nice clear a clear example of
the most one of the most basic types of
double attack but definitely not the
only kind we have a fork we have one one
piece attacking two pieces which
obviously you know which it's pretty
clear you know after looking at this
puzzle for a minute or two that black is
going to lose a piece right not always
it's not always the case sometimes you
know not all double attacks are
unstoppable when there are slight
differences in the position it's easy to
simply defend against certain kinds of
double texts like like so so that that's
you know that's something we need to
keep in mind on as far as you know the
properties of double attack kind of the
mechanics so to speak now let's look at
a another example from one of our club
games this is from the knights
tournament um this came out of a
Scandinavian defense you know they had a
cool little finish which I thought you
guys might appreciate so we'll show the
opening pretty standard Scandinavian
stuff and then we'll kind of skip
through it because we have a few games
to look at
and we'll get to this point where white
achieves one of the strategic goals in
this opening he gets a piece a minor
piece on e5 which black feels compelled
to exchange white continues to get his
head his rooks pretty active and he gets
his queen bearing down on the black King
black brings another attacker on to d4
but also leaving her exposed to some
attack along these open lines on the
Queen side which is what white takes
advantage of then makes a small threat
by repositioning his rook to on g3
forming this nice little battery at
which point he stops the threat
prompting white to move the rook to f3
and then he one might argue unwisely
chooses to capture on d4 you guys think
just exchanging here on d4 looks pretty
straightforward right okay I agree hmm
how can we what's the best way to
continue with white here
continuing to maybe make a mate threat
but also exploiting the weakness on the
blacker on the black back rank yep it's
got two targets under the scope of the
Queen f7 d8 Queen d7 like you said it's
a it's a pretty little movement it was
played in the knights tournament uh by
Manny Manny actually played this and you
found this cool little move over the
board Queen e7 and black had to resign
here we're gonna look at a couple games
we're gonna speed through all but one of
them I'm just getting to the the winning
attacks at the end where we see a lot of
the a lot of the double attack motif
popping up okay my C's was a famous
player from the turn of the century and
known for his attacking skills playing
much in the style of the Romantics and
out of an e4 e5 opening we see you know
the typical kind of theme being played
and attack on the castle King side
position or the castle King position and
blacks camp we see some good aggressive
play by both sides still roughly equal
here
h4n you know actually that the
annotation is incorrect on black is okay
here
white definitely should have considered
Knight f3 but we're not going to analyze
this game too much we just want to get
to the cool position here I'm talking
about some of the possibilities what do
you guys want to play here with black
it's black to move
maybe Knight f6 getting the night off
the back row
now sir
I'm sorry for black it's it's somewhat
it's it isn't it isn't is it's winning
for which night oh you can just exchange
yep you can just trade and get a winning
attack sure because you'll have three
pieces attacking twice defended f7
definitely that's the best move but the
pretty move also winning
it's queen g6 it's more or less
unstoppable at this point you can play
it's not a made is not unstoppable you
you can trade down I'm pretty much and
just be happy be happy with winning
what's that uh yeah that gets it that
gets into some some some big some big
trouble yep but I'm glad you asked the
axe that's kind of tricky to see but the
point of the queen g6 movement like I'm
pointing out it's it's the prettiest but
not not the winningest um there were
more direct ways to convert the position
after Knight f6 there but so King h8
like Kevin saying up here game over okay
so we have a game played between tirage
and Lasker or Lasker and tirage um in
1914 in st. Petersburg during the war
not a World Championship but a Lasker
was definitely a world champion and he
won this tournament in style
I think his opponent tirage he placed
fourth I believe in this one and here
he's playing his namesake variation of
the Queens gambit declined you guys
recognize this opening yeah cool okay
and in this line white tries to saddle
black with the iqp the isolated Queen
pond which can be a double-edged it
creates some dynamic and sharp positions
it's a weakness but it can also be a
strengthen in as much as it gives the
piece with isolate the side with
isolated Queen pond generally has
greater piece activity but he has weaker
pawn structure so makes for a fun sharp
game here when the knight is on when
this guy is on c3 this movie that gets
played in the game
is usually good because it winds a tempo
that makes sense right it kicks the
night kicks the night away here it
wastes the tempo that would have been
better spent playing a move like Bishop
d7 or something like that developing a
piece yes sir and the response is pretty
simple just 93 attacking it with the
knight in uncovering an attack from the
Queen on that newly advanced d4 Kline
also attacking the bishop obviously
which retreats and now Lasker pretty
much the rest of his plan will more or
less revolve around showing how weak
that pawn push was on and really
emphasizing the weakness of an isolated
pawn especially the isolated Queen fine
kind of with some natural developing
moves putting the brook on the open file
happily exchanging the bishop for the
knight retaining that positional
advantage of the bishop there
what's he avoiding here what un'ytu
that's a good that's awesome that yeah
you got your eye on that already cuz
that place the weakness is you know and
especially in the good games the
weaknesses will play a role throughout
the game on for the strategies of each
side but if it were white to move what
would you play here considering that you
have the D pawn pin to the enemy Queen
if it were white to move okay
Bishop g5 Bishop f4 I like those are
both principle moves yeah yeah you get
you get control of that strong diagonal
how about if I told you there was a more
direct way to take advantage if it were
white to move here to take advantage of
that pond which is pinned to the Queen
yeah yeah so he's avoiding that when he
plays this he doesn't want to deal with
that say okay we'll leave this pawn
hanging right here it's pretty obvious
why we can leave it hanging why if I if
he takes it on this move what is why
play yeah rook e1 winning the Queen
right okay which is Lasker doesn't feel
that he can because if he does there's a
cool little Queen trap involved so for
instance but yes you're right
and now he's forced to retreat to the
queenside right because if you play
Bishop f1 immediately then you can just
go straight back make sense right and
now Bishop f1 gets us a decisive
material advantage so Sirach was a
pretty strong player he didn't go in for
that he sees the idea what's the idea
behind eight four though mmm is there
yeah
a4 after playing eight for what what are
we threatening to do right yeah so just
by put were threatening just to play a
five right and win the bishop and we'll
say okay
yeah would it yeah would have done some
good to try and stop the a pond uh but
now he will see his position kind of
fall apart and give us some good
learning opportunities to identify some
double attacks so the answer to 94 is
there should be one where kDa defending
the attacked pond and here the annotator
you know mentions that rook a c8 would
have been would have been preferable
because the weakness is on the Queen
side at this point just began to tell
loudly and clearly and one of them is
that because of this advanced a pawn and
the constant threat of it pushing and
disrupting the the constellation of
black pieces over there in some way the
rook would have been better served on
holding it toward holding everything
together maybe they were just moved to
c8 immediately defending that night but
this escaped him so Alaska was able to
push on get a five in there kick the
Bishop to c5 and continue to create some
long lasting weaknesses namely Doubleday
pawns and here how cool cool looking
move which is you know kind of breaking
a rule that that we hear or I don't
don't put right Knights on the edge of
the board but he's making good on he's
uh
well he's making good on the plan that
he initiated with rook a to c1 by
neglecting to take the pawn on a6 right
now he's he's saying I'm gonna I'm going
to create irresistible pressure along
this long squared along this a long
white diagonal and the start here is
it's a bit of a double threat um it's
the the beginning stages of one okay
there should be six five five
right so he's quite a and even here
we're glossing over some some cool
tactical points so they should be sakes
9f5
all pretty straightforward oh boy you
know attacking pieces you know getting
the knight on that nice active square
I'm sorry right and she's react it's
reacting you know the black the black
side is definitely reacting to what to
whites plans and so what's the threat
here if he takes you know if he doesn't
take the bishop for whatever reason
what's the next move white plays we just
take the knight on c6 right but why it's
quite alright with that because we saw
what happens after that when she
captures here she's quite for Keable
with the rook okay so we get the theme
of today's show showing up and you know
many ways in this game um get the double
attack the most simple of double attacks
the knife fork and black there's no num
num I'm getting I'm finally getting that
e2 pawn that's been sitting there
forever
and they get into this series of
exchanges and now we were noting that
black had the centralized Queen now
white does and it's not she's not going
to be driven away so easily right rook
ideas like rook d8 are definitely not on
the board right now because as mentioned
before and is very you know really
noteworthy to point out that this Knight
is loose because he initiated and
followed through so so well on that plan
of gaining space on the Queen side with
a four a five and putting the rooks on
on the right files and so on this is a
mistake I often make I'll I'll think I'm
better
and then I'll trade down would you trade
their Queens here no no as black yes
yeah because you're gonna that pass pawn
all of a sudden becomes becoming a
strength okay you play like a manual
asker one of the one of all-time greats
okay definitely would not be a favorable
exchange you want to keep your strongest
attacking piece on the board I agree
that's good good chess wisdom attacking
the Queen disregarding the attack to
take the rooks off the board re
centralizing the Queen getting out of
the attack piece of scope just seizing
the open file
driving her to a super passive position
okay you then now you you've got you
picked up on the the basic the basic
parts that make them make the next
sacrificial move that make that make it
work look for some bold moves with white
here what are you gonna play taking
we're on h6 and if I take back with with
the Jeep on what's your idea so I say I
just go through the direct line and I
say hey you're given that take take G
when you say just the square that means
that we're just putting upon there I
know is that what you're saying no g4
it's awesome dude yeah what's the point
well maybe I think no there's a that's
it that's the point is what you
mentioned earlier something there's some
something loose right well the so queen
g4 check the king is forced to move can
then Knight participate and defending
against the check in any way no right
not at all
he's just loose loose pieces drop off
but the famous saying goes um which is
why he does not recapture right he moves
moves the piece away white plays this
motif which would be which would be
super familiar to all of us lining up
our Queen here yeah while we already
have a piece that you know attacking the
pinned upon
and from this point Lasker with a bit of
technique that we are gonna well he has
the past deep on which was created in
the opening in which you know as we
mentioned can be you know the the
redeeming strength or the fatal weakness
SIA and it takes technique to prove it
as the latter as the weakness and since
this is not an endgame class we're not
going to focus on it too much but we
will admire it on that after this point
there's no way that he can hold on to
the pawn because the sole defender can
easily be removed by attacking it with
the bishop at which point yep if he
moves somewhere and if he's attacking
the bishop then we'd probably just take
the bishops off the board and and then
capture the pawn and if he doesn't
attack the bishop then we just take the
pawn oh well this is our winning plan
but we need to remove some of the minors
and then also contend with this guy
before we can convert the winning
position cool all right yeah not a bad
little good little game illustrating the
tactical motif of double attack um this
is a really cool one played by a famous
name that we all know Karpov
against Larry Kristensen most club play
you know a lot of players know of this
one because Karpov doesn't blender very
often but this is a game in which he
actually did blunder white to move what
do you think is strongest sure about you
guys
yeah Bishop b2
okay attacking the knight you're
attacking one piece alright is there any
way you can stay in line with the theme
and double attack
yeah yeah you yeah black has to lose
pieces as our astute viewer upfront is
pointing out how we're gonna how are we
gonna capitalize on that this rare
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to catch
carp off hanging a piece you guys got it
yeah does this make sense okay looks
like you guys got something out of that
I hope you hopefully you enjoyed it hit
like share subscribe see you guys next
time
[Music]